une production du studio sfr nous sans
faire représenter parquet semi le
podcast on parle de convaincre nos
invités d'attitude super jeu quand tu es
avec moi d'une plante et pendant le mois
de juin qui est semi ont une nouvelle
collection en collaboration avec six
créateurs et créatrices de contenu
québécois qui est en fait pour
représenter les six couleurs de l'arc en
ciel en lien avec les communautés lgbt
qui plus est la fraude
puis chaque étui vendus il va cinq d'or
qui va être remis à la fondation
émergence qui lutte contre l'homophobie
et la transphobie donc allé voir les
collections c'est assez incroyable
sinon cette semaine dans cette semaine
justement en lien avec cette initiative
le on ne s'est pas allié mais dany
turcotte site une cause qu'il a toujours
défendues à tours on en parle ou sur
toutes les tribunes grand plaisir bref
de recevoir dany turcotte
aujourd'hui on a les deux grandi en
écoutant mon apparence on a des
départements apa
puis danny marking neutre notre vie
complète liste est vraiment un grand
honneur de le recevoir ici qui de parler
avec ségolène de revenir en arrière sur
104 mon appart sa carrière aussi dans la
vie au sein d'autres projets comme la
petite séduction par exemple dragon
c'est raconter aussi la fois qu'a montré
kim anjar où on a parlé de religion de
vol dans plein de sujets et ce sera un
plaisir on ne rit on a eu du fun
dany a pas perdu une once de sa répartie
à faire rire dit et drôle
c'était vraiment un grand plaisir est
grand temps de les recevoir
guest juste avant la conversation va les
remercier nos sponsors fait que bon
bogush
oui le podcast cette semaine et présenté
par idées cadeaux quebec.com la faute
des pères et dans deux semaines puis si
vous êtes comme moi ce n'est pas l'envié
d'un cadeau qui manquent mais c'est les
idées moi je suis jamais quoi donner
l'eau que ce soit mon père ou à mes
soeurs quand je leur fais ta mère dans
la fin des mers à noël j'ai toujours la
difficulté à trouver les bonnes idées tu
les idées qui vont de faire sourire
quand il va recevoir un bon cadeau le
tir c'est là qu'entre en jeu
idées cadeaux quebec.com c'est quoi
c'est un site web vous allez là dessus
d'avoir plein d'idées cadeaux vous aurez
plus jamais vous serez plus jamais à
court d'idées ça vous faire que de
découvrir des nouveaux produits ça vous
faire découvrir des marques d'ici ça
existe depuis 2009 - j'ai le même
problème que toi je sais jamais quoi
donner quelques jours dernière minute y
arrive le 23 décembre j'ai pas encore
mes cadeaux ou peu importe l'occasion
avec ce toujours des idées cadeaux
- vous avez pu vous allez plus avoir
besoin de casser la tête puis le site
est agréable et facile à utiliser la
gagne 10 des cadeaux québec c'est des
passionnés qui souhaitent vous faire
découvrir en fait des des compagnies du
site e-commerce laquelle on sait que
c'est important on en parle souvent dans
le podcast avec des encourager des
compagnies d'ici en trouvant le cadeau
rêvé pour l'être cher c'est idéal fait
qu aller jeter un coup d'oeil à au site
internet idées cadeaux quebec.com puis
merci de nous encourager le podcast de
cette semaine et présenté par nos amis
chief les peines pic flec-pm peaks est
une application qui est en fait un
réseau social pour le commerce local
comment ça fonctionne vous vous avez une
page flipper que vous pouvez partager
vos découvertes de commerces locaux les
gens qui sont abonnés à votre compte
vont voir les découvertes puis vous
inversement vous abonner à des contres
de personnes que vous voulez suivre pour
avoir leur découverte de commerce le
cours chaque fois que vous partagez un
commerce local vous accumulez des flips
social qui est une monnaie en fait que
vous pouvez utiliser pour avoir des
gratuités et des offres exclusives qui
sont daf les painting fait que c'est
vraiment une façon 360 d'encourager les
commerces locaux d'hommes parlement
d'une découverte faite grâce à flippante
pic
j'ai découvert la barre par coup à
verdun les deux vous savez on est bête à
verdun et le balco qui y participent en
fait chier sur l'application du journal
à la plage de réglages à verdun et en y
allant du sprint limonade au ban par le
cou pour emporter
puis revenant je me suis pris un petit
souper au beau parcours
également bien plus belle ce soit que le
sait uniquement des cartes de métro dans
les terrasses sur ses savates par le
funky ils vont avoir une terrasse le
donc traiter beaucoup à daudet à
utiliser l'application fait un pic
depuis la dernière fois qu'on en a parlé
faut continuer de plus qu'on est des
gens à utiliser cette application
l'appui constate qu'on veut on participe
parce à l'écosystème pause nous
découvertes seront les montrer nos amis
mais le plus on encourage ensemble les
entreprises locales puissent espère y
est ce qu on a même un code promo pour
vous pour vous donner dix mille flip
social à partir de 15 me et déjà des
offres exclusives fait partie des jeux
avec un pied dans l'engrenage utiliser
notre code promo qu'il sf locales pour
10000 flip social en fait un tonneau
dans l'application fait merci flec-pm
pic puis on se revoit dans un commerce
près de chez vous oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut l'année bonjour salut bonjour
on est parti là on n'est pas parce qu'on
est là on arrête d'être naturel ces sept
ans non on fait des forêts
applaudissements à cannes comment ça va
et ça va très bien je pense un bébé au
printemps pour commencer mon encore par
son bel été - ça fait presque 40 ans
mois que je travaille sans arrêt et moi
j'ai la chance d'avoir une pause
professionnelle - c'est que je suis très
heureux de ça j'ai des projets mais je
pense pas trop ouais je vais prendre mon
temps je vais réfléchir pendant un temps
de recul
regardez ce que j'ai fait pour garder ce
qui met à sa fin ouais ça c'est on
parlait justement de tillard le avec
avec vincent vallières qui nous
parlaient d'ambert du monde parle depuis
qu'on fait pas de casque c'est un des
amis qu'on voudrait marquer ça à chaque
fois que je commence une phrase c'est
tout le temps j'avais la conversion du
challenger pays marler dany la semaine
passée puis il m'a dit mais vincent est
ce qu'ils disaient c'était que lui était
rendu à une place où est-ce qu'il
fallait qu'ils arrêtent qui regarde qui
a fait qu'ils veuillent s'en rende
compte
tout est à ce spot lance vraiment où est
ce que te commune et forcé à part ça ça
a été comme une navette bus est en fête
ses 37 années de travail
c'est comme un ouragan qui s'est tout à
coup calme et avec mon roman d'amour mon
départ de lyon n'a pas fait que c'est
comme si j'avais même un peu un choc de
me retrouver comme ça devant rien c'est
la première fois de ma vie que ça
m'arrive c'est que je fais des petits
projets intéressants je découvre des
choses j'avais fait un jardin place ce
soir annonce du gel
j'espère comme tout et de la marne
la fois dans le détail ça va je l'espère
mais j'ai quand même j'ai mission dans
les mains du bon dieu je vais voir parce
que je suis pas sur place pour m'en
occuper mais qu'as tu regarde en arrière
sur ce que tu as fait maintenant tu te
sens eu la fierté
ah bah oui absolument écoute j'ai
commencé à 17 à jonquière au cégep en
art et technologie des médias avec un
une belle gang qui s'appelait groupe
sanguin puis dominique lévêque qui était
un professeur de théâtre puis leur
écoute
depuis ce temps là on n'a jamais arrêté
les projets ça s'est enchaîné d'une fête
2000 spectacle c'est chaud
professionnels deux grosses émissions de
télé est ce qu'on parle rarement de la
petite séduction c'était quand même une
grosse production soit qui a duré 12
harnes l'avenir et du monde qui
travaillait sous les 70 personnes qui
travaillent là dessus à part des gens
des villages devraient applaudir
millions de personnes que je suis sur
l'animateur qui rencontrent is toute sa
cote d'écouté
12h54 jean l'homme je les voyais dans
les villages c'est beaucoup d'énergie
cette émission pour 240 et une localité
à travers le cadre existe 200 cas d'une
émission dans le fond oui à travers tout
le canada j'ai toute la francophonie
canadienne
je pense que vous êtes écouter partout
au canada freins plus au québec on sait
jamais non non non mais c'est qu'on est
écouté par des gens qui sont et qui sont
des québécois mais qui sont soit on le
pot mais même à la télévision on n'a
aucune idée de ce qu'ils écoutent les
émissions hors québec ont visité les
toutes les cotes d'écouté sont seulement
du québec
mes mots quand j'allais dans les
localités nouveau brunswick ainsi
partout les gens me disaient on écoute
tout le monde on regarde tout le monde
en parle on regarde la petite séduction
les gens qui ne s'écoutent qui sont hors
québec en commentaire
ouais ouais on peut voir les
pourcentages des coudes qui provient du
canadien comme quelqu'un d'autre on
prend pour acquis
g ajouté du québec mais effectivement
qui est peut-être monde au québec il ya
sûrement magazine acadienne qui n'ont à
quoi on vous sent jamais mais c'est
intéressant c'est l'attitude sion on
peut en parler plus longuement le dis
c'est quoi c'est quoi que ça tu changes
et mettant quelque chose en toi de faire
tout ce 2 2 c'est une connaissance du
territoire intime je connaissais déjà le
québec dans le canada mais là je le
connais intimement quand tu dis que tu
n'y a pas un pouce d'asphalt au québec
où sujet pas marché je connais très bien
le territoire je connais les jeunes
collégiens roissy c'est sûr je connais
les villages puis je
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration poussé jean
lob des fois c'est un peu jaloux jeu
j'aime la vie de village intéressant
chant fait chaud 2 ouais j'aime la ville
ou un village puis à chaque fois
j'arrive dans un village et une émotion
parce qu'il ya quelque chose de beau de
cette solidarité la de ces gens qui se
retrouvent sur ce territoire qui essaie
de le développer que c'est d'avoir des
projets puis que c'est un microcosme en
fait parce que dans chaque village dont
une partie qui est conservatrice sont
partis qui est plus libérale devrait
vraiment sûrement microcosme de la
société
ça arrivait dans certains villages on
arrivait y avait un groupe qui voulait
pas qu'on soit là parce qu'ils n'avaient
pas qu'on fasse développé trop le
village
quel est l'état qui se mettent à monter
puis arriva world marque société
devienne une ville de yanji et déjà qui
nous regardaient étrange les flashs la
petite section
on leur a jamais dit que c'était vrai
j'arrive en place il y est arrivé deux
voitures il y en a qui parlent potes qui
tue la sangle h 15 j'avais l'impression
d'attendre la palestine peace mme jean
est en guerre à l'intérieur du village
puis le rescue me tonti on pense on
pense à saint-élie-de-caxton avec fred
pellerin qui est vraiment y fait un bon
sens mal tourné ça a mal tourné oui ça
va les êtres humains sont mais oui exact
l'exacte l'espèce de grid et entrer là
dedans mais est ce que la petite section
ça avait un effet sur ces villages là
après c'est plus un effet al interne
reste était plus un effet sur la
motivation des joueurs sur la solidarité
du village le fait se regrouper ensemble
de ces communes saint jean baptiste de
plus il y avait une fin de semaine où
tout le monde est ensemble tout le monde
travaille ensemble satisfait délié dit
j'ai des beaux souvenirs le rappelle à
tous à lac-mégantic où on était allé
après le drame
- et là on avait vu vraiment la nouvelle
rencontrer les gens dans leurs drames
qui était pas terminée puisque avait
fait une émission touchante c'est beau
c'est magnifique j'en ai plein des comme
ça devant ça c'est des souvenirs
incroyables way absolument je te dise
pas que je réécoute les émissions les
orienter mais les souvenirs de travail
d'équipé aussi on était tout sur la
route toute la gagne
pendant douze heures donc on a tissé des
liens vous avez des coupes se forme et
j'ai vu des coupes se défaire en vue des
enfants à naître
jeudi des enfants qui ont été conçus
dans certains villages mais on avait été
dans le c'est comme une famille en
tournée à tout l'impression que qu'un
retour un peu ou village à l'attrait du
village à la paierie la pandémie un peu
propres provoquer ça oui j'ai les amis
le ticket qui sont achetés et quelque
chose dans un jardin parce que c'est
moins cher aussi pour le trip de
s'impliquer d'une communauté depuis 2001
avec la technologie tu peux tout à fait
travailler de l'extérieur de maurer sans
problème avec le télétravail c'est
encore mieux
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya un mouvement
qui va les y ait déjà un mouvement vers
les villages vers les campagnes
est-ce que ça va durer et ceci non non
ça c'est sûr que tout ce qu'on aime de
montréal n'existe plus exalead restera
ya pas de boy a paru tout bandes
masquées qui on parle qu'on les touche
c'est ça que c'est l'ambiance est un
petit peu anxiogène
j'imagine qu'elle soit cas ça va être
pas c'est que tout le monde va être
vaccinés que la vie va reprendre à
montréal peut-être quel retour à la
terre va se calmer un peu je souhaite
que je qu'on doive puis de toute
évidence les visages des villages que tu
peux te dit tu dis village chouchou
minutes ont marqué parce que on a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup je me
rappelle en nouvelle écosse chéticamp
avec roch voisine les gens tellement
calme là bas puisqu'ils connaissaient
même pas croisé l'étudier il me parlait
plus à moi qu'à roch voisine parce
qu'ils connaissent un peu mais ça énerve
un peu plus que sur le genre
avec sa célèbre c'est un beau village
tranquille avec des gens charmants avec
des accents exceptionnel quand tu vois
où tim hortons tu comprends même pas ce
qui se dit innocent comme en fait c'est
du franglais comme radio radio mais
journée là mais ça ça doit être quelque
chose de beau de faire le tour du québec
pour entendre les petites routes les
influences qui ont eu de l'extérieur
pourquoi la nouvelle écosse et l'anglais
passe passe qui habite à 10 ans globe
c'est normal qu'il y ait un petit peu
d'érosion qui se fait dans le langage
puis en gaspésie bête une section qui
est un petit peu plus anglophone new
carlisle et toujours puis c'est le clown
lévesque et n'est d'ailleurs pour ce qui
est devenu nationaliste parce que je
connais que les angles puis il ya le
nouveau brunswick basse est la province
la plus ultime à plus bilingue au canada
puis c'est déjà super sympathique j'ai
tellement mangent et dorment dans ses
douze nous attendait toujours avec ce
qu'ils avaient de meilleur faisait que
oui si simple le supputent les meilleurs
du terroir de chacun des villages si
chacun des fois c'est perturbant les
acadiens d'une certaine certains
endroits aux autres ce qui marche et de
la poutine râpée
ah ouais bah oui ça c'est pas beau de
patates de patates a rappelé qu'ils
étaient bouillis dans avec au centre une
espèce de moto2
delors salle et unsa s'est brouillée par
la d arrêt d oeuvres d art ça devient
comme grease à allah comme un peu de
futurs noms mais j'étais avec michel
louvain dans ce village 3,460 des
questions avait quelque chose pour pau
pour moi mais tant que d'entendre
j'étais là avec roch voisine directe
richer louvre quelque chose non mais
michel louvain ça beau souvenir parce qu
on était devant 300 personnes qui ne
faisaient déguster la pornographie
piñata des notes vertes est lui trop
poli pour tous les fans en ile de france
et je vendais la attend la réaction côté
la soirée il ya il fallait qu'il passe
sur l'heure du midi à leur passé parce
que le moment donné sur l'heure du midi
ils y ont demandé d'aller chanter la
dame en bleu au foyer de personnes âgées
qui est allé leur chanter ça
bénévolement jaunards du midi puis il ne
tuait deux semaines incroyables
il était très gentil mais c'est risque y
est obligé de faire son coming out après
sa mort c'était ça c'est que ça ça veut
tout dire
c'est plus ça comme symbole ouais ouais
c'est qu'il peut y était pas capable
d'assumer ça de son vivant il savait
très bien qu'un décès d'un il s'adresse
savoir plus il était président m'avait
dit que je n'avais pas à me l'a dit on
ne tue pas la poule aux oeufs d'or
on vous l'a dit qu'ils voulaient pas
façon comme une arme pour pas de
décevoir son public en état des dames à
qui chantait l'amour c'est d'un bleu se
sont jamais tout et de rien bah je pense
qu'ils faisaient du denim d'un milieu
savais je ne vous le savez
comme phosphorescent mais ça c'est ça
c'est cesser ce cas c'est terrible mais
c'est beau par exemple qu'elle sait se
sont simplement ta belle se met sur son
antenne et vidé ses comptes à son
conjoint ils se sont mariés avant sa
mort ah ouais ouais parce que je me gêne
pour une vue légal c'est plus facile
hocine qui met vraiment pas longtemps
avant qu'un couple de longue date le 25
ans on les appelait monsieur et madame
michèle loup texas avec la wii elle
allait aussi dans des bars gays il y
avait quand même une ville n'était pas
il n'était pas dans la garde-robe à
double tour mais au niveau des entrevues
gmail a mentionné le fait qu'il y avait
un conjoint est ce que c'est parce que
toi c'est une cause qui quittent et
charles évidemment puisque une attaque à
choisir une cause exacte
est ce que parce que c'est vraiment une
position difficile
quelqu'un en qui populaire ou du moins
qui est dans l'oeil du public de
chapeauter une cause comme celle là sauf
qu'en même temps on dirait que c'est
tellement important de le faire que y'a
comme ce sentiment là moi moins que moi
qui vois ce vraiment de l'extérieur ne
vous plaît pas du tout comprendre les
différents niveaux tout ça mais on
dirait que c'est quasiment pour ceux qui
s'en viennent fait baisser avant si leur
avance bien il reste qu'il reste
quelques dinosaures mais la nature va
faire son travail mais je dis y'a il ya
beaucoup de chemin qui a été fait en
1979 c'était la première gay pride à
montréal ça s'appelait la
aguerri la guerre mais ils étaient 55
dans la rue avec une escorte policière
pour pas se faire lancer des objets et
houleux c'est vraiment des gens
courageux à l'intérieur de sa y avait
mon ami laurent mais carte jaune qui est
un des piliers de la guerre des
communautés lgbt qu plus exception
existe une vierge
mouais bah oui au début trente ans il y
avait 55 personnes qui maintenant il ya
deux millions de personnes dans les rues
calmes maintenant des médias cacho qu'il
ya quand même du chemin qui a été fait
il ya des familles qui vivent un soutier
ça veut dire pas de famille ou au point
guy lesbiennes sur garde sont toujours
un moment que je m'attaque pas que c'est
bien marié que tout le monde se demande
ce qui moi dans les villages où j'allais
y avait toujours j'avais toujours des
confidences de tout le monde parce que
d'un village encore plus c'est possible
on pense que c'est monsieur pas circuler
les ja sont bas ya beaucoup de non dits
et beaucoup de légendes disent pas mais
tout le monde le sait c'est comme si
parce que s'ils disent que ça va très
grave mais finalement tout le monde le
sait déjà
ça changerait rien ce serait maudit
adema dame qui venait me voir ma fille
comme vous mais comme vous on a encore
malgré tout le travail qui a fêté besoin
d'utiliser des effets mécaniques est
question de soutien où je me souviens de
cépie et homosexuels tout le monde
enfants je me fais à dire nicholl
nicholl son conjoint son ami ton amie
nicole c'est toute mon enfance et son
ami mais tout à l'heure son ami peeta
magnétique compris c'est tout cas d
absence
bien mal et j'ai compris par mois - mais
n'empêche qu'il tend vers la porte de
chambre
les amis des achats les bras simon mon
hôte matin tpi son conjoint il sait son
mari ou stephen jones et son ami mais
qu'on disait c'est ça qu'il ya quand
même quelque chose encore dans le
langage qui est des fois on atténue les
pubs brisé tes oreilles dans drive
l'impact entendre c'est son conjoint
mais le plus mc de l'amour et ces gens
là qui blais pote dire sa base auto
aussi quelque part ce petit monde évolue
à son rythme aussi pilar chaque
génération il votera kényan aujourd'hui
je pense que dans les écoles les jeunes
y découpe de filles des coupes de guerre
puis même on est rendus même plus loin
que ça et lui n'ont binaire oui
d'ailleurs eu beaucoup faxer ce spectre
et la wii ware est vraiment entre la
génération justement michel du vin la
tienne pileux la prochaine et michel
girouard aussi des terres qui décident
est aussi presque matin michel louvain
curieusement lui c'était le contraire
lui avait fait un coming out en 70 s il
y avait marié son conjoint devant tout
le monde
ou le contraire totalement il était
totalement l'avant-garde mai
sans voir son look quand même de coup
les gens le trouvent sympathique je
pense qu'un personnage public puis c'est
un chroniqueur artistique locale de pau
extrait du patinage des précurseurs
j'ai du respect pour lui parce qu'il ya
eu le courage d'être humains y allait
avoir le courage de ces cas là c'est pas
tant cette époque là c'était très
courageux
puis tiens on a fait beaucoup de cas
depuis depuis ton départ de tout le
monde en parle d des commentaires
homophobes dessus sur les réseaux
sociaux mais j'imagine que pour les
commentaires homophobes et au sud dû
recevoir des commentaires
sûrement extrêmement touchants de jean
louis keita profondément et d un mec
plein plein plein plein plein plein
plein surtout après ma démission pour
avoir su mais sérieusement j'ai une
tonne et une tonne de commentaires que
des gens qui me disaient que ça rit ça
va aider à cheminer avec leurs enfants
que le fait que je sois bien dans ma
pauvre que je sois athée lire chaque
semaine ça va aider du monde ça me fait
énormément plaisir de faire tout un
risque j'avais reçu de mauvaises choses
dans les autres années j'ai juste
l'accumulation l'autunois aurait pu
continuer mais leurs 16 ans et demi là
chaque saison j'avais 4 5/10 scandale à
chaque fois ça vient l'eau puis j'ai
pour la couronne de guillaume guillaume
c'est juste la couenne dans un moment
plus cette attaque la saison se termine
moi je pense que oui
on jase encore on s'appelle choix mais
se sont ressaisis y ait une fin de
saison difficile parce qu'il ya eu en
plus aux cards and we secteur qui est
déjà pas parce que les gens savent pas
c'est quoi un producteur qui passe c'est
notre boss qui était accusé de ça mais
c'était un des producteurs que tu que
jamais mis sur angers les pieds mais
dans le contenu il avait aucunement
faire açores
au final c'est quoi c'était plus un
ennemi ni l'agent jack chaud mais
j'allais côtoyé pendant ces 16 années là
c'est un cas que je sois plutôt
sympathique héros qu aucun signe avant
coureur d'un genre de chose qu'est ce
qu'il est souvent peau de femme a même
en confidence j'ai mes enfants ne jamais
ça c'est pas le genre d'affaires c'est
maintenant éric salvail qui servent à
part que tu gardes chez vous le tuez
j'espère genre d'imagés parle de voir
mais je veux dire le procès va suivre
son cours
on va savoir ce qu'est ce qui s'est
passé vraiment parce que l'eau c'est
vraiment on ne peut plus des 10 points
cinq chefs d'accusation on connaît pas
les détails mais non mais effectivement
ça a été une saison rock'n'roll d'envoi
le laisse plus rock'n'roll que deux je
me souviens des pigeons on dirait que on
dirait dans les premières années tout
bon à part londres et qu' il ne peut de
ces plaintes et des controverses
ouveillan toujours eu à chaque année
mais si c'est parti d'une émission
festive au début on nous a donné des
caps elle partait bien à 200 personnes
dans sale [ __ ] avait comme cinq sujets
comique puis un sujet sérieux on s'est
rendu six sujets complètement sérieux
c'est l'un des pires drames da semaine
c'est de ce qu'on parle allons te
demande de faire des blagues dans une
position impossible quand je regarde les
autres alips ça me rassure beaucoup mais
oui c'est un giga lui est là il est
super bon et je parle pas ne pillez
probable par les salue c'est un des
meilleurs humoristes au québec qui est
l'un des plus naturels en main propre
crise n'est pas capable il m'a kavala 10
rebonds on se tourne à l'angle 75 fois
avant de parler ça tu l'humour
totalement ici ça s'appelle sans fil
mais l'avancé comme 40 films - donc je
dis si je dis ça il va arrêter la forme
est déjà trop tard
car juste tenté de faire des jobs de
vaccins pizza qu'ovide puissamment donné
l'ambiance anxiogène de lakovic vim
parce que le depuis 2004 cas ce que mon
chéri depuis le début fait clairement la
répartie et encore le sens du mot
période avant 16h lac blanc qu'est ce
qu'on boit qui s'y colle mais mais
effectivement qui est tout le monde à
part cela dit c'est une expérience
professionnelle exceptionnelle
j'ai rencontré tous les gens que j'aime
j'ai été gâté j'adorais mon expérience
sauf peut-être la dernière année en
direct pas de public que je trouvais
franchement plus rough mais je trouve
être parce que je pense que même de
l'extérieur c'est moi dans ma vie puis
le fait que je suis active ses réseaux
sociaux puis que j'essaie de rester à
l'affût de l'actualité était juste là
dedans on dirait que le monde en parle
ça depuis les 17 ans que ça roule c'est
le toujours été le reflet on dirait de
la société parce que tout le monde parle
de ce sujet là et puis cette année moi
j'ai vécu mon année de la même façon on
dirait que je la voyais à je la voyais à
tout le monde en parle c'est à dire des
des sujets et féministe et la whey exact
d'affaires qui s'est fait une job de
rêve porte le nom de sa porte
moi je vais garder ça j'aime et j'ai
fermé mais factice et j'ai vu étaient
tous appuyé il montrait que je le vivais
en temps réel depuis qu'à chaque à
chaque dimanche
ça faisait comme le sommaire de l'espèce
de semaine anxiogène que j'ai vécu puis
il y avais tu pouvais pas d'en sortir le
team mais six mois plus ma confiance
s'effrite est pour rien du bourdonné jeu
très ramassé tout faire avancer c'est
comme un test un humain l'audition sa
force de sa frappe et tu viens que tu as
passé liste un traumatisme que j'étais
rendu que j'ose même plupart
j'aurais même pu intervenir je juge du
couple modèle monsieur camara loges aux
affaires je suis le pire des racistes du
monde après avoir été le tueur de cochon
la semaine noire non notées en fait les
deux on est on est des grands fans de
demandes par mois des routes épineux je
passe je pense que je me rappelle
exactement j'étais ou le lundi le
lendemain de la première
ouais la première première la première
première quel âge aviez moi j'avais 13
ans quand j'étais en secondaire 2 puis
on avait un coup comme ça c'est un cas
port à elle la première non c'est pareil
c'est ça mais tout le monde ne pense non
mais c'est la première qu'on se rappelle
la base spatiale qui est miss était
musulman la mise sur la carte mois mais
non mais moi je me rappelle c'est ça on
avait un cours d'histoire puis notre
prof d'histoire le premier le premier
sujet qui est abordé
c'était l'impact que tout le monde en
parle
allez avoir des relais après la première
émission est la première émission du
genre aussi une zone moi j'étais un
deuxième année je l'avais écouté mais en
deuxième secondaire du monde la victime
mes parents puis le lendemain le prof
il savait déjà que savait que ça venait
de savenay dette inquiète charles keller
qui allait rester lotis marc desjardins
qui s'appelait marc déjà on aime moi je
te prends mais tu es enfant tu crois
ouais ben oui oui vous l'avez vous venez
au mvp puis après c'est moi je veux dire
des épisodes j'en ai manqué maximum 20
maximum pas non plus dans dix sept ans
je n'ai pas manqué d'en manger en manque
depuis j'ai pas tellement bizarre d'être
chez nous puis de le regarder je disais
ça qui je vous regarde
puis-je vous jure c'est sa jeunesse
calais tu me tannait qu'elle je m'amuse
à voir
écoute moi j'ai pu et je veux vraiment
pas comparer les situations le mais moi
j'ai fait occupation double
4 4 en 4 5 1 puis puis maintenant je les
écoute puis juge les gens comme je
m'étais fait du jpy comme moi j'avais
vraiment mal reçu le jugement des gens
parce que j'étais là y ait du montage
arrêtez vous comprenez pas le mot je
regarde les caisses qui a fait au final
chez très fier qu'est ce qu'il ya
derrière ce n'est bref si ça ne te
telegraph a nettement pâti clairement je
pense à nous influence dans ce conte
fils qui l'a diffusée lundi matin en
général c'est que ce qui s'est passé
tout le monde en a parlé à tout le monde
qui souvent ici on voit si t'es des
entrevues de tout le monde en parle
c'est ça donne des idées ou même des
fois on s'inspire d'un vite et qu'on a
vu à tout mon argent pas combien de fois
je reçois un chèque de dexter tout le
monde en parle diffusée à quelques pas
je vis juste mes médecins pour 10 et
pourra revenir à ce qu'on parle est en
toc est même nous qui est un peu comme
tout le monde a peur on essaie d'être un
peu reflet de ce qui se passe
actuellement il est de ce que les gens
parlent de gérer beaucoup d'éclectisme
psychose ah oui c'est éviter qu'ils
viennent de partout société puis je t'ai
l'actualité apprécié de nourrir notre
réflexion qui soit et on invite des gens
qui est qu'on a envie de parler du sujet
qu'on se parle qu'en plus on est qu'au
locle c'est que ce soit on parle la
cuisine plats faudrait cette année
parfois de vous voir non mais on prend
des moments on n'est pas tendre à 200%
ensemble tout le temps non plus mais
tous pour dire que nous aussi de la
dernière année à maintenir il a fallu
qu'on fasse elle ces sujets lors et
prestige allure après celle ci ils sont
comme imposé par reposer parce qu'à
mener je dirais qu'ils arrivent une
tragédie mambé n'a pas de sens après ce
aller faire des jockeys avec intel qui
peut pas signer et juge
le par les gens si on n'a pas invité
telle personne seule phase i c'est ce
qu'elle faisait des seuls fonds dits
demandé qu'on fasse qu'il faut aussi
balancé ça avec des entrevues plus
légères parce que les harmonies celle ci
c'est ça nous joue sur le moral nous au
toussaint les ja aussi qu'ils écoutent
tout ça partout ils ont besoin d'un peu
plus de 6 ans auront à être collés
toujours sur l'actualité mais sélectif
sur les aspects négatifs l'actualité ça
devient avocat mais je pense qu'on lui
demande si c'est là la réponse
l'autre jour j'étais je te tomber dans
un trou sur youtube
ça m'arrive des fois de partir sur une
coupe de recommandation puis je tombais
sur l'entrevue de pierre falardeau
oui à tout le monde en parle mais c'est
ça c'était un beau souvenir aussi je me
rappelle que je me rappelais pas toutes
les formes et autres membres étaient
flous dame dans ma mémoire mais je me
rappelais poc à quel point ça pouvait
être comme patriarche mais comment ça
pouvait être irrévérencieux par la liste
un personnage exceptionnel aussi des
filets yellow devant toi tu y arrives en
faisant l'objet d'arrêtés fumer plus
qu'une seule chose qu'on faisait au
début qui poseraient absolument oui
même une réelle à l'époque c'était de
l'intimidation que j'appelais avait fait
aujourd'hui ça passera plus par un
l'attaquer physiquement il ya pas nier
le toile elle la top puis tiré dessus
peu importe qui tu ferais pas ça
quelqu'un dans les cordes hui ce serait
des éditoriaux piaggio en direct un
intimidateur de pire espèce c'est quoi
c'est quoi tes entrevue les plus
marquantes pour tous et pas de ceux
souvent des gens qui sont peu connus
c'est pas les vedettes qui m'attirait ne
suscitait plus des gens qui avaient fait
des choses exceptionnelles
me souviens de plusieurs lans trop de
nancy marrante que j'en parle souvent
mais c'est une dame qui était venu
assister à l'émission avant de mourir
avant cancer puis un de ses rêves c'est
d'assister à tout le monde en parle et
on est allé la rencontrer en coulisses
puis on a toi tellement à lui mais
tellement exceptionnel guise se savent
attendus d'être invité la semaine
prochaine qu'on l'avait invité à
l'émission baptême nous nous raconter
sauf sa fin de vie
l'aide médicale à mourir y sava était
une entrevue exceptionnelle sur youtube
si nancy mawn mwm les gens qui veulent
regarder ce pas tout de suite leur garde
mais c'est une belle entrevue est arrivé
avant une perruque père s'est assise
puis l'arrivée sa période devant tout le
monde
coup de théâtre cela dit moi j'en ai
pour autant de mois vie nous nous
raconter ça c'est magnifique
j'ai des frissons quand il y en a eu
beaucoup comme ça me souviens d'une
femme aux sicav l alzheimer avec sommes
quarante ans non une française qui était
venu voir nos méthodes auprès des
personnes qui souffre d'alzheimer lie au
québec
puis je me souviens que son mari nous
avait dit avait fait une très bonne
entrevue sa étaient toutes présentes à
la super bien puis la femme avait même
avait dit vous avez préparé des cartes
le mot cette trilogie fallu gérer après
par une bille le lendemain je prépare un
cap je vais parler à son mari d'avoir
bien sûr n'est même pas capable
je n'ai pas détenus allaient me that
it's a qui savent jamais sa mémoire sa
part très vite comme ça ouais
puis tout ça fait mal de ne pas voir
s'étaient tus les jeux parce que je
savais pas ce sujet le plus étant donné
puis d'abord j'ai jamais eu de jugement
c'est la première chose première non
mais j'ai fait des gaffes j'en ai donné
des mauvaises j'en ai donné des bonnes
j'ai fait au cours des années il ya des
choses qui auraient pu passer
aujourd'hui l'autre
ça n'a pas de bon sens il y en a
d'autres que c'était pas si grave que ça
mais ça a fait des tempêtes re caroline
néron à la cep je me souviens de
plusieurs camps qui ont fait le 11
janvier beaucoup caroline néron en plus
c'était pas si méchant que c'est juste
que je disais que je veux rien trouvé de
boue dans son catalogue
c'est très influencé par comment la
personne qu'elle a eue d'autodérision
s'arrête tout changer mais c'est que
c'est jusque était officier succession
qu'à ce moment ça passe pas exactement
quand les qu'ailleurs il ya des dépôts
débat des scandales d aplomb se demande
qui se passe c'est quoi la semaine après
c'est quoi le debriefing après thirsk et
qui est comme un charge de la gestion
est ce quelqu'un qui vient vous voir
qu'il est le seul à gérer mes insultes
les gérer mais y'a personne qui venait
de dire refait puceau ou non j'ai jamais
eu de remontrance que j'ai jamais eue
nécessairement des non plus on me laisse
à moi même organisé avec métro c'est que
c'est ça ça dure en général une ce quart
d'heure ça se joue à peu près 4 jours 3
4 jours m'essayer intense je me suis là
caroline néron entre autres lots je
recevais des insultes là ça rentre lcc
c'était à chaque fois ça devient comme
un peu pernicieux parce que tu as
toujours voir si tu dis je vais arrêter
d'aller voir fermer son contrat que t'es
pas capable de parler voire pilotes
usine à rentrer en corse en hausse dans
les derniers séminaires web le thé
lipton pour ses jugements négatifs fait
que me redonner sa ça finit par ta
taille même si tu dis moi jeune carapace
fort si cette affaire direct c'est un
truc qu une enseigne et jeu ça finit par
avoir un effet sur tout après 16 ans 3
ans et demi j'ai comme rendu les armes
jeudi motion année je quitte le bateau
je quitte la cuisine et on dit est en
fait trop chaud que très brefs supporter
la chaleur qui est accusé mme bachelet
quitte et fait qu'au lieu que la
carapace s'est renforcée sacré temps
c'est toujours une petite coche de plus
à chaque fois dans le fond ouais bah
c'est sûr ça chez lui je eu à l'usure de
toutes ces années là puis aussi le
plaisir qui était disparue pas si
j'avais encore du plaisir à faire
l'émission j'aurais continué mais le
fait qu'il ya pas de public que star
disait qu que j'avais une marge de
manoeuvre parce qu'avant c'est avec le
montage quand même qui me souvent je
tentais des choses on les a enlevées au
montage puis j'étais pas plus grave que
ça
mais là quand tu tentes de quoi tu
restes avec le sens exact exact puis les
gens sont de plus en plus à craquer
aussi aujourd'hui comme des gens qui se
sont emparés des médias sociaux
puis c'est vraiment un minimum de gens
là c'est pas la majorité des sas et là
c'est la minorité bruyante ayant trouvé
cette façon l'autre s'exprimer sur
twitter ou sur facebook
mais c'est ceux des fois c'est bizarre
tout ça tu regardes une femme qui
techrine ben c'est épouvantable tu vois
moi j'allais voir c'est qui ce fameux la
halde est enfin là ben bayatt écrit
peut-être qu on se souvient que c'est ça
ouais y'a déjà sont forts chez les gens
sont forts chez jean s'affranchissent
aux besoins sont encore plus fort chez
depuis la pandémie je pense qu'on a vu
ça l'est vraiment exacerbée avec love
vivement complotistes aussi qui c'est
chez des gens en colère aussi ça c'est
des gens qui avaient voté pour donald
trump s'est tous les gens qui ont voté
vous donne attendre ça des gens en
colère lui c'était comme un espèce de
soupape qui a disposé de les sauver tout
ça bien marché à manger sain raison de
ce côté là justement de ces espèces des
anguilles l'extrême droite le lundi kiki
ci qui est très active au québec on a
toujours pensé que ce qui existe
absolument qu'ils sont québec petit au
site
vous êtes aussi que je te manquer avec
les blacks comme carole ses plus lourdes
côté le qui font des imams et à des work
de deux bars en fête des instits et
aider les gens qui ont lancé des
insultes puis des intimidateurs du web
google
c'est quand j'ai tous les bars et
partout le tam mathieu bock côté est
venu à tout le monde à part j'ai juste
du bout des lèvres suggéré qui était à
l'autre bout du spectre de l'extrême
gauche
j'ai comme suggéré que peut être
peut-être de l'extrême droite c'est
parce que je pense mais c'est ce que les
gens ont pensé et là j'ai été ensevelis
moi aussi ça c'est sûr des gens qui
combattent les eaux
lang s'était dit wow de l'autre bord
c'est ça la faf
au final on peut importe ta position ou
peu importe ça vaut toujours froid si
quelqu'un tout le temps lui est toujours
quelqu'un qui vous insultent et peu
importe où tu situ ou de 15 jours tout
sur choix des politiciens maintenant il
ya toujours les sytèmes polariser les
politiciens si à chaque semaine on se
faisait traiter de péquistes de
fédéralistes de 2 d'eads à genoux devant
trudeau d'inde à genoux devant le pq des
dates où on a tout eu les insultes ou
ses bébelles pis le pire c'est que petit
jetant dans des tentes ou tu disais un
scandale ça dure quatre jours puis c'est
tellement mettons quand tu es quand tu
essaies de les rationaliser le ca
apparaît tellement simple mais j'ai eu
et j'ai déjà vécu un mini scandale pour
nièce ville saint pie le ch'ti j'avais
la boule dans le ventre pileje de l'eau
puis j'ai regardé mes messages rentrée
puis je me sentais pas bien par j'avais
d'une affaire où je pense que c'était
j'avais fait la promotion d'un sac de
chip qui avait la poutre de l'aide d'un
mot je t'aurais qui au chili le mot
celle ci est égal à ce qui est offert
j'avais mal au ventre ce type de thé
bien rigolé quand un peuple est
d'allergie je suis je t'ai entendu tu le
dis
jetez vous était calé depuis je pensais
je pensais que c'était ok fox et puis là
deux jours après ça s'est fini c'est
fini tu n'entends que j'aurais pu fermer
mon ciblant le m allez au chalet de ma
mère pendant 48 heures
revenir à montréal puis j'aurai rien
vécu de ce rien ayant une curiosité
maladive à savoir ça va s'essouffler
justement le problème il n'attend pas
être tu veux la voir venir mais tu veux
regarder comment cela se déroule puis tu
veux voir s'arrête un peu pitié mais au
final ça finit tout le temps et ça finit
par fuir puis souvent rapidement on est
des gens qui ont besoin d'attention si
ouais on est dans ce milieu l'os pour
moi rien quand même quelque chose on se
plaint des médias sociaux
on était tout à light tout le monde me
des photos puis veulent que les gens là
n ont jamais mis aussi en fin de soirée
montrer notre dopamine 6 comme la
nouvelle cigarette c'est un besoin tu
vas voir j'ai mis une photo la voix
c'est assez rare mais faut toujours
faire appeler qui sait c'est juste les
marchés qui commentent ils hésitent et
sookie c'est ceux qui équipent tête au
monde en parle c'est qui qui sont là
chaque semaine je trouvais bon depuis
qu'ils aiment et ce qu'ils aimaient
baroudeuse on n'a jamais vraiment est
rien sûrement sur aucune plateforme sauf
qu'on est les plus assidus qui tripent
sur le show qui des fois des fois trouvé
mais tant que je suis pas une
intervention que le fait était peut-être
pas précisément juste tout ce qui est
normalement que tu as fait l'était
vraiment outils et vice versa avait avec
gilad s'est plaint pas sauf que jamais
de la vie
c'est juste qu'ils resteront bénéfique
semaines qu'on l'écouté parce qu'on
adorait se dire mon rôle dans l'émission
il pas évident parce que je ramasse les
graines qui tombe à terre dit à tout le
contenu au combat il ya toute l'équipe
de recherche qui ne travaillent que pour
lui pour y préparer ils ces entrevues
tout est là tu t'es sur carton moi je
sais qu est ce qui est sûr le quart
temps sur les cartes en lui je peux pas
toucher à ça c'est sans compter avec moi
je rame or jusque tard
puisque homme qui essaie de trouver des
petites antilles c'est beau cadeau juste
dit majoritairement poser des questions
ce qui est la daube des guides et fois t
il servir en échange mais souvent je
pose une question beaucoup tcc sens mais
lui garde un espèce de con c'est parfois
plus que d'autres mettaient souvent
gérant s'est passé parfaitement clair la
position d'eads et des guides et
guillaud sur l'enjeu de la dirm mai mais
ouais mais ça c'est drôle je t'aime à
l'intervention ne déguisent
je trouve que c'est ça c'est comme
précurseur de l'eau on dirait que je te
manque un petit des tentes où il ya de
la de la voie plus rough l'aide parce
que là il ya eu cet événement là qui
vient juste d'arriver en vérité
puisqu'elle est bien plus je le
comparais forgé le journal de montréal a
remis ça à la botte parler de la sphère
de monsieur wiseman qui était arrêté
pour agression qui ont mis la photo qui
fait que les gens qui sont peu informés
ou qu'il ne s'informe que par ça ils
vont dire guy étaient accusés c'est les
gens qui les japs il ya une bonne partie
des gens qui lisent le journal mariale
qui l'aiment pas d' avance laitiers
comme ceux qui rentrent en ligne de
compte aussi deux ex machina taqbaylit
alors jaunissement de la pire espèce
mais même à les hanter en glace elle
dans les entrevues qui est qu'il donne
il était récemment on le sent plus à
cran quand même une grosse saison de 19
émission aligne aussi les fatiguer moi
je lui suggérerais d'assesseurs parcours
mais joie depuis que quitter le qu'elles
ont été mes tantes été dernier moules en
termes de est-ce que tu as réussi à
vraiment qu'un décrocher vraiment non
honnêtement je regarde l'émission chaque
semaine
je suis encore le fil sur twitter de
tout le monde en parle j'ai encore
reliée à 7,16 à c'est un groupe puis je
regarde les autres qui sont les fous et
les folles qui sont en s cré ce que tu
le regardes un peu à 1
je regarde ça c'est sûr avec une
connaissance profonde de l'émission non
je regarde ça aussi pour voir comment
les jours les autres vont se débrouiller
dans l'action
chaque intervention chaque geste chaque
regard analystes langage non verbal à
s'avancer de jeter connaît ses
mouvements l'iccat est plus facile et le
jeu des hommes et tout mais en faisant
podcast justement tiki torpeur c'est
encore plus longue entrevue pis mais
somme toute c'est sur le ton que ce sont
plusieurs choses ça ça se rassemble je
le vois tellement plus maintenant ah ok
c'est un stylo il est dur interviews et
austérité loti 6 tonnes pas vraiment
plus maintenant sur le montage et des
beaucoup parce que souvent il y avait
quand même un bout d'entrevue moins
intéressant qui est qui amenait un beau
intéressant son fils a été coupée
effectué hier d'un juste le bon mois
puis au dessus des fous pis des folles
du roi verrait préféré qu'ils sont à
nice est bonne mais la haye fougueuse
has done mais elle a déjà eu cinq
menaces de morts partout c'était
toutefois peut-être pas présent dans le
fonds belge est pas pour eux parce que
là c'est sûr qu'au début moi j'étais un
peu d'ail effet ça y'a rien qui me
dérange en rien kim atteignait en fait
il avait même pas de nom ce qu'il y
avait une boîte de courriels qu'on
recevait puis nous avons enlevé l'accès
parce qu'il trouvait que ça nous dérange
j'ai compris que c'était un peu malsain
pour nous d'aller voir sa tête temps en
temps des jaunes des critiques mais ton
qui devait peut-être commenté un peu
l'émission à autre mais l'émission tu as
plutôt bien reçus en général - puis mais
leur cas twitter est arrivé là
la misère salon gens peuvent écrire
n'importe qui n'importe quand c'est
épouvantable sur facebook et gens
peuvent appeler mais à trois heures du
matin l'organisation facebook
madame qui qui qui qui était perdue je
peux trouvera faut que tu ailles un
facebook crise se sait qu'elle en ait
deux moins taxés sur exact ça s'apprend
j'en ai trop là faut pas que ces tests
en troisième on va le chercher un autre
dérivé qui ont animé ces lefa les médias
sociaux aussi à plein de bons côtés mais
oui c'est la fil twitter pour s'informer
il rien de mieux lance un sort à chaque
minute ça se renouvelle constamment die
hard belle perte de temps maudit
poursuivre les bonnes personnes les
banques ont depuis une fois c'est moi
c'est moi c'est ma règle maintenant si
j'essaie de pas juste oui frais chez mon
film sans arrêt du bout française mon
fils je n'ai pas eu de nouvelle écosse
heureusement malheureusement plus jeune
étudiant en littérature ce que je que je
fais si aussi de l'évolution d'une
langue les influences qui rend rafraîchi
montée l'actualité bavaud - stif
j'ai apprécié mon fils d'actualités sur
twitter mais j'essaie de ne pas le faire
de façon inconsciente juste parce que
j'y pense j'ai cepici pas réussi à 100%
mais j'essaie de me dire je peux prendre
dix minutes après la journée ou au début
la journée tchèque assure avoir
l'actualité oui il ya toujours quelque
chose qui attire son attention fait que
c'est sûr que ça gruge du temps je lis
moins de l'île de puissants l'homme
ouais malheureusement c'est ça je lis
des articles que je lis des choses les
journalisme des choses je recherchais ça
fait tout ce temps là je le pense moins
à perdre est que notre concentration est
moins élevé ont eu tendance à voir ap
avoir des affaires plus rapides plutôt
que de s'installer dans un livre de lire
150 pages dans l'après midi on veut
changer de sujet en vue d'autres choses
on veut saper notre tête est programmé à
saint josse forcer à le faire je pense
il ya eu des messages finir ken follett
le mail page
c'était bon mais ces dix années
accrochez vous faut se forcer des
moments où est-ce qu'on le met à off
parce qu'on fait trop de choses sauf si
on lit des choses mais si on n'y a pas
juste des photos du show il ya des
choses était tout à fait puis est ce qu
est ce que j'imagine que pendant 16 ans
tu devais de rester à l'affût de
l'actualité
constamment oui constamment que je suis
toujours toute façon c'est comme une
drogue j'aime ça pis tu l'étais avant
mais c'était avant balaie tout le monde
en parle peut être orienté veut plus
l'actualité puis l'hommage continue je
peux je pourrais pas m'empêcher de faux
choix au courant de tout ce qui se passe
je lis des articles surtout je me
faisais ça comme là on est tous des
spécialistes la pandémie mais maintenant
oui mais pouvant notre offre et nos
recherches mais on est une année on est
écoeuré gerrard avant mon deuxième
astrazeneca que je pense que je reste je
rêve que je demande à voir une thrombose
comme si tu vois les services complets à
l'hôpital en n'ayant pas de risque de
covile non mais c'est un chant vaccin
qui était donné par tout en angles aba
millions de doses un peu partout puis a
pas eu statistiquement temps 2 2 qui
sort mais c'est surtout le monde disait
le risque de ne pas le prendre pour
évaluer beaucoup plus gros de risque de
pas prendre ton accent sera mis à
voyager mais ton stade et putride partie
d'après ton a probablement que fera
partie comme vient de nouvelle écosse
ouais ok on se connaît bien mon jargon
lui il n'y a pas vu sa famille ça fait
un an et demi aurait fait qu'on avait
prévu d'aller tout le mois de juin on
avait loué une maison qui borde la mer
en face à 14 jours de quarantaine en
arrivant pierre péan sur deux soit deux
semaines à visiter sa famille mais en
objet d'un nul ayant fermé frontières
d'un nouvel écran
sont-ce pas strict l'étranger des
éclosions comme jamais fait classe ascan
peut-être mais on va attendre que les
mesures sanitaires se calment basque à
lévis et des gens fait objet de le
parler sa galerie parle de l'entraîneur
maison c'est pas très agréable c ou c ou
la première place que tu peux aller en
voyage quand ça va mal mais ton le 11
ans se dit dans je sais pas d'avancé 6
mois ou est-ce qu'on se dise mafia au
débat riz à metz une bonne idée c'était
à bali c'est beau c'est magnifique moss
moi je vais sûrement éventuel voisine on
est je vais retourner parce que c'est
j'ai pas vu mais j'ai pas vu ben ali ben
j'ai besoin d'aidé
quelques spots mais j'ai pas vécu ben
ali mettant là mais c'est sûr je vais
retourner c'est vraiment le vrai but
magnifique
j'aimerais salle en asie à quelque part
j'ai toujours rage et à la ben ali
chalet en jordanie gens là d'un
déplacement en afrique j'ai monté le
kilimandjaro oui ç'a bien été
ouais ouais ouais ben c'est une [ __ ]
projette foule j'avais embarqué
là-dedans peu naïvement à quelle année
c'était peut-être 12 angle ça dure à peu
près dix jours de monter
le sommet c'est 6000 m peu à peu tu
perds tu étais fonctionne mal partout
tout le monde est malade nous souvient
le dernier soir on était tous couchés le
au pied du glacier bon d'entendre des
sons dans chaque candidat à la montée
quand c'est le mot roi demeure des
réseaux center puis tranquillement mais
moi j'étais chargé que je réagissais
bien au manque d'oxygène parce qu'on
devient le conte ont fait le 100 miles
comme si on voulait on avait marché 10
km la dernière journée le dernier boulot
il est tellement difficile à accomplir
décembre après c'était pour entendre
tous les muscles ou t'as pas mal
commence à faire mal au risque de lasser
comme dans l'autre sens ça ça dure deux
jours mais moi j'ai pas dormi pendant
dix jours
hier soir il y avait un médecin avec
nous il m'avait donné un somnifère
puis j'ai tellement dormi là qu'il y
avait un groupe de diesse qui jouent aux
cartes
c'est moi qui les dérangent air corse
que je ronfle est trop fort je n'ai pas
dormi depuis tout ce temps à l'altitude
ne faisait ça je dormais pas fait pour
une fondation
c'était pour qu'air canada ouais c'est
ça je me rappelle de ce wpt est à
l'appel de ce moment là puis à ses
succès ds quand même démonté un peu
luxueuse parce qu'il ya des gens qui
portent toutes le conflit ne digère pas
c'est s'appuie mais ça et on pourra pas
le faire sont forts et le matin quand je
suis arrivée de nuit en afrique là
j'avais jamais vu kilimandjaro je
devrais t'informer un peu mais pas
beaucoup
le j'ouvre ma fenêtre d'hôtel je vois
cette montagne j'avais jamais vu une
grosse montagne comme ça de ma vie
puis on partait à 5 heures du matin pour
montrer que j'étais déjà en décalage de
12 à long terme et puis le lendemain
comment se vit en fait que pas eu des
climats thaci jean mermoz pour ça que
j'ai pas dormi parce que comme un 12
heures de décalage lewis fait que
j'étais d'ecalgrain pendant la nuit puis
tu
j'ai fait de la randonnée au pérou le
justement pittis insistait de la
randonnée luxe une équipe qui est haute
et on partait le matin marché autres
démonter et anti nous dépasser hervé
pierre montet randy jones et des
africains qui sont habitués de la montée
en montagne à fond combien de fois par
année puis il était habillé avec des
vêtements que nous on envoie faut que tu
voyais magog sports radio canada mais il
n'y avait pas de l'équipement comme nous
on dit souliers pour sentant un peu mal
bref quelqu'un j'ai fait ce que j'ai eu
au moins si le lendemain le temps de
relaxer on a fait une coupe de petite
randonnée pour s'acclimater à l'altitude
pitt ce puits apprécié en italie dans la
grande ronde mais commencer dirais que
moi j'avais été dans une clinique du
sommeil à montréal où on m'avait testé
on m'a mais on m'avait mis en état de
manque d'oxygène par la nuit avec des
petites choses partout que pour analyser
mon sommeil voici un grillage servir
chaque jeté comme un cobaye avec tout le
long de la montée j'avais dit sur le
corps pour analyser mon coeur analyser
mon oxygène analyser comment j'allais
réagir les boutiques ne sais pas comment
tu vas manger en exactement ce qu'ils
sont en super g et les petits les petits
lièvre logiquement trouvent ils
finissent par être malade et c'est
exactement trente secondes mettant mon
père qui était lui ai vomi métis avait
pas de corrélation justement avec la
forme physique ou non ce soir comme il y
en a certains qui est une autre facette
frapper fort quand même
ben oui mais non mais moi je n'étais pas
un malade présente au sommet mais j'ai
réussi c'est combien de temps ça prend
la montée 8 9 jours
puis une fois que les rendus en rouge
magique c c'est gratifiant le dessus le
temps de la pression il plaide top de
cigarettes
rihanna qui sait comme une fierté de
fumel cr et henry oui mais après ça moi
moi j'avais pas de fun parce que je
savais que faire et compte 200 ouais
ouais pas pu l'apprécier pas vraiment et
en plus il était supposé si tu as
tellement gros qu'on était supposé
devoir la rondeur de la terre mais cette
journée là il y avait de la brume fait
convoyer harry j'ai tout le monde soit
pour briller à l'élite au plus haut mais
cécilia puis y'a pas un ego de sa job
c'est pas les ménages à ce mini au top
des règles c'est quand même une route
extrêmement fréquentes et puis c'est sûr
il faut qu'ils avancent même nous nous
excusons est tout ouïe
ces toilettes qui y traînent faut pas
que ça reste la compose pas dj ben ouais
là dessus il y avait une foule monstre
ça très loose et insuffle achalandé où
il y avait votre groupe date il y avait
plein de groupes de partout d'allemands
de toutes sortes d'aidés des religieuses
tout à faire c'est vraiment comme une
cesse comme un joule extrêmement
touristique
sachez qu'elle est vrai est rendu à
aussi dramatique fait la queue leu leu
lancé puis d'un coup il peut y avoir un
qui tombe à côté le tapis loin de
prendre des photos en haut le pourquoi
pas pour justement parce qu'une photo
l'année passée qui circulent et c'était
cette espèce de file l'oeil les les
visites ont quant à eux chuté dans le
monde qui voulait augmenter la grèce ils
sont comme peints de guingamp c'est les
rayons dit ok plus loin de prendre des
photos de la fille faut prendre photos
de vous autant aux meilleures photos qui
se prend là ça fait une mauvaise
publicité ça fait la mauvaise pub pour
j'ai pas du dixit fed allait monter de
montagne finalement c'est juste fait
leur arrivée en haute était tabou depuis
il faut que tu attendes deux heures
offrant une industrie touristique payant
pour résoudre messieurs qui portent tous
nos bagages tout ils font comme d'autres
de salaires des enseignants pour redorer
un peu son taux cible mais par contre
pour l'heure ces artistes pour aller en
justice tape tellement l'altitude
souvent qui use plus vite que nous exact
n'est autre qu'un corps était justement
à bali et
me sandrine qui était un gay qui j'étais
a beau talent un voyage à l'île de java
puis y avait des il y avait des gars qui
monte un volcan pour aller chercher
quelque chose d'en haut ils descendent
le type il faisait ça à longueur de
journée et puis leur espérance de vie
était comme le 25 à 26 en cause qui se
tenait il était dans le charbon tournoi
mais il faisait quand même pour leur
famille tu peux te dire ce ticket il ya
en a qui sont moins malades leur vie
carrément moins donnent leur vie pour la
famille le site stocks pour amuser les
north american way pour que nous on
arrive là puis on paye gens regrettent
assez d'être et non mais samassa masala
vraiment repousser les frontières de ma
part ouais parce que c'est la chose la
plus difficile que j'ai faite fait qu'à
chaque fois que j'avais quelque chose
dans ma vie où ça allait vraiment pas
bien je me dire elle me rappelait
toujours du kilimandjaro que je parle
comme justement gérer toujours seul non
mais c'est comme pour moi c'est une
référence deux doigts de souffrance plus
de mal être je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
fait ça mais après chaliand safari c'est
quand même agréable mais j'étais allé
jeter leur lait là l'est du kenya puis
il ya en voyait-il juste l'ombre du
kilimandjaro l'a vraiment au loin même
il y avait quelque chose de il y avait
quelque chose qui venait me chercher
vraiment beaucoup le jury qu il y avait
le ciel qu'on avait comme l'art africain
l'eau dans les puits mais j'ai trippé
sur ernest hemingway beaucoup le dans
mon parcours puis elle lui a écrit
justement les neiges du kilimandjaro me
il y avait quelque chose lol qui venait
vraiment le chercher qui était comme
vraiment profondément en moi puis si tu
sais la décrire le jeu passe ici tu es
tu avais sts web un oui mais moi j'étais
touché par l'afrique en général parce
que je me rappelle la première journée
quand tu arrives honneur pour notre
traverser tout le pays
dans cette dimanche tout le monde était
pour tout le monde était bien blanc
c'était parce que les gens ça m'a
tchèque le dimanche les gens iront
respect de la sont religieusement
puis j'ai pleuré quasiment toute la
journée c'est sur ce texte
j'étais prêt mais j'étais ému ému émues
d'être là je ressentais quelque chose
j'sais pas quoi je peux tellement
spirituel mais j'avais j'avais quand
même quelque chose qui me restait je
trouve ça magnifique de voir ces genres
hd tout est tellement beau et belle tu
dépasses spirituel dessus je peux
croyants de toutes époques croyants non
de tuer été élevé dans une famille
croyants mon père est un croyant parce
qu'au saguenay
ma mère les femmes de cette génération
l'on peut rejeter la religion pour
plusieurs raisons parce qu' ils ont été
malmenés par la religion ils étaient
obligés à avoir plein d'enfants puis il
y était pas gentil avec les femmes la
religion les femmes sont jamais très
bien fonctionné choc ya des femmes comme
janette bertrand
nous on réagit fortement au port du
voile par exemple se défoncer voyons son
don m'a agressé mais sa cause que cette
génération de femmes qui ont été
traumatisés laval donc on sait qu'ils
sont honnêtes ils parleraient d'audience
et un point de vue qu'on n'a pas souvent
qu'on consomme souvent mais je continue
ma mère à la 83e et pour elle la
religion c'est le diable non à veut rien
savoir mais mon sous toutes ses formes
sous toutes ses formes puis même là est
de plus en plus âgé a perd la mémoire un
peu mais je pense pas qu'elle va se
convertir avant sa mort ouais ouais
parce que c'est trop profond ce sont des
mesures qui est grand puis ma par contre
mon père lui était très religieux
jusqu'à sa maison c'est moi qui ai
préparé ses funérailles avec le curé
nous connaît rien là dedans mais par
respect pour lui bien évidemment on ne
fait un service religieux avec l'anzhi
caltex vous aimeriez avoir jeu qu'une
idée quel texte que je veux le gie
pareillement aux belges par les gamins y
était il ya fait des choix puis c'est un
bon curé il a fait un bon discours à
l'église s'est rappelé de son nom c'est
déjà pour moi c'est déjà bon et en fond
il faut partir quand infantilisant parce
que je me souvienne de m'étendre le
curry talent hier nicole était une
chenille
aujourd'hui elle est un papillon
des fois je sortis l'église la métaphore
cible c'est la première fois qu'on
attendait cette méthode
des fois des fois l'épreuve je suis allé
à l'église trois quatre fois par année
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que j'aime et ont 23
j'en ai tremblay depuis j'y allais pas
parce que je t'ai experts religieux j
allais parce que la famille à sa famille
à l'epp noël pâques puis la times un
baptême ou ou venir on verra si ça fait
de ces raisons le petit des fois j'ai en
pagne et cdd price qui était qui était
vraiment il faisait ses clients
s'appellent qu'un qui ils font leur
espèce de monologue il est comme un i
prêche après je te l'homélie mais bon il
faisait sa petite idée qui peut être
freestyle pays partait dans une shirli
impossible ploemeur telagh mais sort et
on se regardait puis c'est une vraie ce
qu'on est en train de c est ce qu on
veut on dirait qu'on n'est pas dans même
planète ou pas sam pendant même se
façonner aussi par la religion qu'ils
ont tenue toute leur vie les autres et
dans leur monde à eux ce qu'il dit c'est
bon alors que dans notre monde à nous
ils sont dignes en décalage total entre
eux et nous le souhaitons rester dans ce
monde là ouais exact j'allais au vatican
j'ai visité toutes les
c'est tellement à la foire et voient le
temps passer tellement riches tels mis
tellement de richesse au vatican c'est
pour entendre
je me souviens au vatican et à la poche
du vatican tu peux envoyer une lettre
puisse et j'ai envoyé puis ça a pris
quatre mois
je l'avais envoyé à la blonde de mon
père était morte quand leurs forces et
pas très efficace
jol son pass canada ici mais pas mais
c'est beau la ccsa vaut la peine de le
visiter le 7 août il n'y a pas personne
qui aurait les moyens de se payer des
musées comme seul mais alors ce soir
l'église
pis les costumes piles et les curés aps
les
yang et sous roche certes mais moi mais
mes grands parents étaient séparés de
jeu quand même puis mon grand-père son
plus jeune frère c'est comme l'a encore
l'époque qui s'en prenait 1 dans famille
qui devenait prête
puis le plus jeune frère émile il aimait
lieu milieu seuil est devenu il est venu
prendre puis est devenu évêque est
devenu archevêque tapie a été arrêté au
vatican ii l'on tenté le manager comme
retraité humanitaire au vatican pitot
depuis lui justement fait exactement l
inverse de la métaphore dash nuit du
papillon le quart des revenus totaux
papineau ricane
mais quand ma came à gramat est décédé
lui testé les hôpitaux publics
l'intellectuel la famille bayavuge du
quai aussi était-il une connaissance des
de la bibliothèque puis quand ma grand
mère décédée est venu piquer ya fait son
free store c'était juste tellement
hermétique personne n'a rien compris
il sait comme d'y aller dans les
situations des citations de la bible en
parler un langage concombre a été
déconnecté de la déconnecter après 7 il
ya mes tantes
j j ai fait un discours spécial pour
pour faire vivre notre sol quelle
personne qui accomplit décédée a dit
mattar d'état religieuse - ma tante
huguette puis j'allais la voir à chaque
année je vais l'avoir h qu'outil mis par
ce qui est en train de mourir
j'étais la voir mourir quatre années
parce que ma réponse là elle c'est drôle
parce que ça va savais pas comment
réagir socialement puis a donné des becs
mais de façon un peu mal à l'aise en
vrai que savait pas comment agir avec
les gens c'est qu'ils me donnent à me
donner un bec l'asub bec pour rouler
comme ça puis était dans sa petite
chambre tout seul est accrocheuse juan
copala toute sa vie en mission à coucher
il n'y avait rien dans sa chambre il y
avait une photo d'une amie qui était
religieuse
c'était tout ce qu'avait dans sa chambre
qui a raconté que son ami est décédé
qu'elle l'avait lavé puis caillavet dit
le savons il était parfumé qui n'ont pas
le droit de se laver avec du savon
parfumé parce que c'est comme du luxe et
qu'elle l'avait son ami avec un savon
parfumé paille a dit le savant je le
prends sur ma conscience est avec toi
c'est moi non mais le mien parce que
cat's paw sa sauce le parfum du savon
autant qu'ils aient autant qu'ils
étirent des jackpots joystick analytique
et l'allusion s'en est mis plein les
poches
autant caennais qui ont donné leurs
études ils ont tous dit ce qu'ils
avaient pu tout l'été puis pour pour la
religion puis pour l'éducation aux
couilles étaient des gens qui inquiétait
de bonne foi là dedans charpy avait pas
juste des smartphones il met des bonnes
personnes pendant un mois le paren ma
soeur il était prêtre puis il a été
prêtre vraiment longtemps puis à avant
de quitter dans le fond la prêtrise il
disait que le quitter parce qu'il
tombait amoureuse d'une de ses
cuisinières puis a dit le moins je veux
quand je mets mon amour de ses pieds il
disait qu'il était rendu quasiment
gérant quasiment gestionnaire plus que
prête
ercom trois paroisses le fallait qui
gère les fonds à qui étaient allouées
aux paroisses puis été rendu à faire des
levées de fonds mis assez de payer des
travaux visent à faire le bien c'est
plus du tout pourquoi je talent elop ça
fonctionne put ccc l'attrait de la
chaire qu'ils doivent se faire sortir le
royaume où des exactions
non mais tu peux pas te dire est un être
humain tard pas de sexualité ça pas de
sens ça sonne comme la paix historique
en un possible quand tout le monde
dépenser tout le monde a des pulsions un
pic en syrie réprimée mais savent ça
sort tout croche en s'excusant c'est
pour ça que ça fait déjà un peu
tout croche je devenir curé devenir curé
c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est quoi tes
plantes aux tout petits des projets
présentement gtoi projet d'émission de
télé mais il faut que tu as en face
plusieurs pour canal qui fonctionne
il y en a qui pourrait être intéressant
que je travaille
c'est sûr les personnages humoristiques
des années 90 ce serait comme un
portrait des gens qu'ils ont créés et
que moi je crie dany verveine mon
personnage
il y en a eu beaucoup dans l'histoire de
l'humour au québec ça nous distancier ça
nous distinguer totalement de ce qui se
passe aux etats-unis de ce qui se fait
en france
on était comme un hybride théâtrale et
stand up maintenant c'est devenu juste
du stand up à l'américaine
wouah dans le tas il y avait plein de
personnages viennent encore pense à gaby
gravel qui est un beau personnage de
laurence l'ont pris une bonne question
on ne reçut en or sur la façade
maquilleuse elle est super drôle il y en
a plus il y avait quatre levac et
beaulieu puis c'est le fun n'est pas ça
ce serait un genre de ce serait comme un
espèce de retour sur ce personnage là
comme un aliéné avec des extraits des
archives toi qui en a quand même
beaucoup
oui mais où l'on selon george heck
danielle lamy fait que ce soit pourrait
être intéressant en allemand on a reçu
michel courtemanche celui-ci le puits
nous parle de la création des
personnages c'était vraiment super
intéressante si c'est ça vient d'une
idée
cheick anta marge sur ebit en soi oui
personnage en soi fait que se renforcer
j'ai le projet de documentaire que je
travaille encore sur le vieillissement
des personnes lgbt qui se font
malheureusement ils sont victimes
d'intimidation foyer pour sans danger
dans les foyers de personnes âgées way
qui sont obligés de retourner dans le
placard parce que ils peuvent plus
parler de leur vie parce que les gens
qui sont dans la résidence riz deux
autres puits se moque d'eux puis
viennent comme seuls dans leur coin il
parle plus à personne puis viennent
faction ça mais de quelle façon horrible
de quitter le monde
est ce parce que c'est une génération
c'est la première génération avoir fait
un communard de l'histoire parce
qu'après la loi le bill omnibus en 1969
que le père de monsieur justin enfin qui
a libéré un peu les personnes lgbt tic
ça devenait la sphère privée restait la
sphère privée ce qui se passait d'argent
m'accrocherai denjean me coucher ça
c'est comme la de la lutte des
communautés lgbt 12,69 1919 puis parce
que je le parle
justin trudeau y mais ça c'est le début
la dé l'autre faction vous ferez comme
une espèce de retour sur tous appuyé en
même temps on parlerait à cette
génération là que lutter autant
j'aimerais ça interviews et comme une
lesbienne gai lgbt q j'aimerais savoir
combien de chaque des beaux personnages
des gens qui ont beaucoup de choses à
dire qu'ils nous racontent l'histoire de
cette lutte la sogem réseau fait que je
travaille là dessus on est en train de
le présenter un différents diffuseurs 8
août à lyon même aller vers les
plateformes netflix budget c'est le
genre de sujets qui les intéressent même
un pic qui intéresse le monde entier oui
mais oui ça pourrait être le fan depuis
que je travaille là dessus
puis tout agirait comme un animateur
producteur ce thread je serai plus à ses
animateurs animateur puis est ce que je
m'éjecte participerez activement la
réalisation nager un réalisateur avec
moi qui s'appelle christian la lumière
on y donnait là dessus
on touche pas les um le nord dans l'ère
du présentiel pendant m'acheter un
plexiglas
finalement c'est que dit même si c'est
pas des meetings confesse et des
podcasts guichet vous des podcasts et du
spot idéal et on les en éléments banques
pour plus tard puis un autre projet
aussi j'en ai quand même quelques-uns
cas par rapport aux portes et convient
de parler le type il je pense aussi à la
série qui est débile un chouette fait le
dribble laquelle j'ai participé d'accès
c'est encore dans des familles jeudi
difficile cette question le tpiy 4
attend du monde par exemple comme et
éric duhaime béton qui dit que je
finisse de l'obs et réglisse à face à
d'autres mettent à la main moi je sors
tout ce qu'ils disent mais moi tout ce
qui se dit mais quand même c'est la
controverse il aime ça provoque et c'est
un personnage et je le trouve
sympathique aussi mais c'est ça lui aime
ça allait à contre-courant ya me semble
provoquer les jambes ça fait partie des
choses le servette sion a crime
soubassement crise parce que là ils se
disent victimes d'homophobie
c'est complètement son livre et puis bon
il a directement fait c'est juste pour
avoir été remanié
l'amanite peut pas juste être factuel à
ce point le jeu mais ça existe bah oui
ça existe est incrusté c'est dans nos
mémoires c'est les lois sa charge
facilement mais les mentalités
si c'est comme un cru cité comme un
fossile dans le cerveau des gens il ya
des gens pour qui ça va être longue
tant qu'il ya des gens qui vous diront
jamais passé - est pire qu'avant qui
s'est éclipsé du mahb il reste des
luttes afin justement quand je parlais
des personnes et des personnes amenées
dans les résidences qui se font
intimider mais ça c'est un autre combat
qui va falloir pour ça c'est la première
génération qui arrive à large des
résidences dont un e-mail ou ces genres
si les autres les emp ainsi sans
complexes que la mentalité des autres
dans le fossé sur le même sont acceptés
dans vie à l'extérieur car avec des gens
de leur génération ça pose pas parce
qu'ils ont passé leur vie dans avoir des
amis qui étaient issus de ces
communautés love sexe est une mentalité
qui va bien mais là on les sort de l'eau
pour les envoie dans un autre milieu où
il ya eu pas d'acceptation fait que
c'est
c'est une fin de vie dramatiques
c'était il faut faire de quoi les aînés
on a parlé plus tôt mais plutôt
aujourd'hui avec avec catherine fournier
était les années pour plein de raisons
mais j'avais je n'avais jamais pensé à
saint lô tu fasses ya cet aspect lundi
ce qui est super intéressant pour pour
un documentaire
j'espère le faire j'espère le faire
avant qu'ils meurent tous des filons ses
projets mais moi j'avais pas l'habitude
d'aller chercher de l'argent pour faire
des projets ça c'est nouveau pour moi
c'est que c'est là on me manès radio
canada avait dit oui la cause la plage
la pandémie est arrivé
comment veux tu allé interroger déjà
j'ai demandé qu'on attend que ça se
calme un peu pour pouvoir avoir des
vrais entrevues avec des gens puisqu'ils
le grand défi ça va de trouver des gens
qui vont vouloir parler pas cette
génération là il y avait tendance à
réduire à cacher tout puis si j'aurais
essayé de les convaincre je pense une
bonne personne pour ça parce que leur
dire qu'il faut qu'ils fassent oeuvre
utile pour les prochaines générations
piquant par là bas ça va aider les
autres à ce que ça arrive plus c'était
vraiment dans dans les moeurs de cette
génération là juste c'est arriver
n'importe quoi justement tu te faisait
abuser par le projet au québec c'est
comme ça beaucoup c'est quand les gens
remonter le temps à table le monde est à
marzens on parle pas français parle pas
de politique sans parle pas de ça on
parle pas de ces foulées mais le karma
est en train d'aider ont pu exploser
ces évolutions la police a besoin d'être
a pignon sur tout d'affaires dans les
médiations c'est que les médias gêne
réaliste on demandait aux gens de
s'exprimer de calais les médias sociaux
sont arrivés tout l'été les journaux ils
disent écrivez nous donnez nous votre
opinion dites nous ce que vous en pensez
qu'on se retrouve avec tous des gens qui
veulent tout dire tout le temps leur
opinion sur tout j'aime pas ses cheveux
comme manager de la section commentaires
c'est nouveau je voudrai avoir utilisé
utilisait la presse journal de montréal
les points 500 commentaires en dessous
du lit 4 c'est ton retour tu aimes et
écoute les nouvelles et tu réponds pas
demander aux gens de s'exprimer pas vrai
ça ils sont obligés d'enlever les
commentaires qui ont passé que l'art et
on demande à tout le monde de donner son
opinion tout le temps je mettais en plus
d'aider des ongles un commentaire en bob
c'est tout tu le dois aussi des poètes
d'accord que ça reste dans ton salon
jetés avant ça reste à taverne je dirais
les gens seuls s'obstinait à taverne là
dessus ça restait loeb c'était ben
correct moi j'écoute tout voilà par
annie quelqu'un dit quelque chose et
avec lesquels je pas d'accord qui peut
juste le penser que je pas d'accord la
société pour toujours besoin mon opinion
mais moi je tendais un piège aussi
samarie de m'exprimer sur les médias
sociaux donner mon opinion mais est ce
que c'était vraiment nécessaire que je
le fais moins je le fais moi je plusse
voyeur maintenant je regarde les photos
piscine à ces mots doivent c'est moins
de vlad c'était moins impliqué aussi le
noise
puis parlant des projets à mener
admettons-le dans un monde et peut-être
c'est quoi ce que l'an prochain ou
l'autre d'après m guillaume dit on se
marre hualien on a un public dany
devrait pas encore lisse et on a un
public en face au jus dit en fait ce
montage
c'est comme le passé je pense ça
reviendra jamais comme c'était loin je
pense à soi pas une bonne idée de
retourner à quelque chose choquante a
pris une décision tu veux continue puis
c'est comme ça je dois passer à une
comparaison que les uns et les autres
qui l'ont fait plonger plus goût
vraiment ça
j'ai pu goût d'être dans la controverse
le goût de faire des choses qui vont
être utiles qui vont me plaire qui vont
me rende heureux qu'ils vont être
agréable à faire que ce rapport
polarisant j'ai voulu faire des choses
sales rassembleuse et que j'ai coincé il
semble prêt septième jour j'ai travaillé
beaucoup honnête match pourrait ne plus
travailler
ouais ouais je reconnais que les
prochains projets qui ont fait la
tournée des podcasts gens naissent à 67
ans alignés mais les fêtes d'alphonse
outre toutes les prochains projets que
tu vas faire ça va des projets de coeur
et que tu vas faire pour toi je ferai
les peluches et des agneaux marine home
away te dire comment je vais pas de
contredire or mais j'ai assez donné là
dedans tiji pas ce tempérament là non
plus le nez dans la controverse alors
que guy lui celle-ci comme dans son adn
mais moi non je sais faire une vie riche
il ya de quoi aussi de faire c'est de
faire des affaires qui qui amène juste
du l'ajout lcp ben oui ça aussi c'est
quand même c'est le fun c'est possible
john mettant la défense en fait si on
fait pas de casse plus d'actualité des
fois on fait comme recevoir quelqu'un
qui nous parler des exoplanètes puis de
la vie extraterrestre
des fois ça fait du bien c'est juste le
fun de partir dans ce sens le type de
bien la curiosité aussi c'est tout
m'intéresse aussi moi c'est ce losc à
gaza aujourd'hui peut-être ça peut
changer dans tout ce qu'on réagit et pas
nécessairement dans le béton d'affaires
saut à 2005 où elle jette un set
je rappelle la plupart du temps
s'appelle pas d'avoir déjà dix ans c'est
rien 15 séquences relation s'est jamais
clair n'importe où chaque semaine la
question qui tue mais il ya eu tellement
de monde mais c'est plus délicat d'aller
danser à mme nuland même l'humour h
s'est transformée avec la pandémie noir
c'est devenu plutôt que chez les sujets
sont les la glace est plus mince
qu'avant
tu penses tu que tu penses que ça va
revenir
on va être marquée par sa mère sans que
ça va rester longtemps dans notre
imaginaire c'est les gens qui ont
véhicule à l'appel en 1918 la grippe s
les espagnols y en a plus sont morts
mais on en parler pendant des
générations le ma mère a le plus connu
mais sa mère parlait de ça parce qu'il y
avait des gens dans leur famille qu'ils
étaient morts de la grippe espagnole
dans l'époque il y avait même pas de
vaccin et ça a pris comme trois ans avec
sa cellule une image n imagine si marine
ça prenait 3,6 apprenant qu'en un an et
demi ben ça peut arriver et on sait pas
moi je me prononce plus sur la pandémie
à ce que je suis très mauvais choix un
bon astrologue de pandémie parce qu'à
chaque fois je touche trop positifs
j'avais toujours l'impression que ça
allait finir puis ça finissait jamais
fait que l'eau je sais pas il peut
arriver un va rien qu'on apprend à venir
il peut arriver vaccin qui a des effets
qu'on a pas vu venir
il peut arriver des choses aux pandémies
que je prêt à tout le moins
nous prônons mois la semaine face aux
semaines passées c'est là c'est la
première fois depuis le début puis je
suis chanceux de pommade jamais rendu
l'âme je l'apprends forte depuis le
début ou est-ce que j'ai une soirée dans
l'appartement où est ce que je me
sentais comme un début de crise le un
début de crise anxiété de comme je suis
prisonnier puis je tripais papa antonio
a dit qu'il fallait que je sorte parce
que même après le couvre feu il faut que
je sois illégal il a juste parlé de
marche que je marche le long de la rue
que je reviens dans autre chose qui est
non si ça passait c'est la première fois
que je chante elle a sept ans que
c'était là me suis pas quelqu'un
d'anxieux d'envy fait que j'imaginais
quelqu'un qui était prédisposé
maintenant avoir dix mais c'est ça qu'on
voit tout il ya beaucoup de gens qui
souffrent d'anxiété s'éteint le mal du
siècle en a énormément fait que cette
pandémie la exacerber cette anxiété
lorsqu'on voit des jeunes on voit où ça
nous offre révéler les gens autour de
nous on a vu le ceux qui sont plus
anxieux ceux qui sont tous complètement
irresponsable d'andré que ça dans nos
familles on les bois puis c'est ça
révélateur la pandémie mais oui c'est au
dans les moments de même hausse que tu
vois la nature des gens exactement
ouais ça permet je suis mode je suis à
toi tu l'as pris rapidement après j'ai
rien eu même pas responsable à la place
mme angèle en jeu juste allergique aux
gays j'ai fait une grosse crise a mené
j'ai passer la tondeuse dans un idiome
puis j'ai eu comme 12 piqûre sur la
jante la fasm a enflé à wake ne savais
pas avant
non pas du tout jamais fait à ce point
là mais là je rentre à l'hôpital un choc
anaphylactique est tous là depuis
s'arroger un traitement à toutes les
tours momin g20 piqûre de guêpe dans le
broad je venais je vais venir des états
unis la place
il plaide baisse de marché noir ses
portes à des programmes et a ouvert un
gap c'est un traitement qui existent le
ca existe pour toutes les allergies fait
maintenant ça extrait pour mousser la
rive gauche je pourrais qui te fait
accoucher qu'un chien ça c'est parfait
mais c'est pour ça qu'elle vaccin pour
le mans qui m'a rien fait parce que j'ai
tellement devenait dans le corps tehran
plus de gameplay
non mais ça ça me donne des effets à
chaque fois toutes les deux mois tout au
moins je vais puis l'âge et comme
beaucoup de fièvre je viens malade mais
le vaccin n'a rien rien fait pendant 38
ans et son beau succès rien s'il fait
que l'être mais là dans le fossé cei ont
annoncé qu'ils devançaient les les
deuxième dose de gaza la scène et coop
il ya eu on va apprendre cette semaine
pour les autres vaccins c'est comme ça
j'ai passé assez vite
moi j'ai l'impression que je vais
pouvoir aller chercher ma deuxième 12 le
7 juin
enfin 14 jours plus tard je devrais est
immunisée fait jour faudrait voir ma
famille au saguenay c'est ce que j'ai le
plus à ma mère j'ai hâte de prendre ma
mort dans la salle joe drake aisément
pomme
mais comment les interactions c'est vrai
mais quand même l'interaction de ces
mômes et on le sait ce que je donnerai
plus de bex ajout d becks a ajouté l'ex
- des tirs du milan qui a brassé dans
l'ariège le travail de fond alors juste
un salut mais la poignée de main je
m'ennuie de somain la poignée de main
ouais je trouve ça quand même une
attaque quelque chose le même panier
mais c'est maintenant le tyrol bonjour
vexé jouga fille
pourquoi ça va être moins déplacés puis
pilota fort que j'ai réalisé le lagotto
de fight le soufflé les bougies
je suis un supporter donc mais tant que
la personne soit faite à l'est la grippe
le même sens qu'un gâteau places au toit
et en coupe le gâteau tout le monde en
prend un point c'est la perana oui mais
oui ça n'a pas de sens et brassac à
chaque automne d'avoir porté le masque
un peu probable la main pour la ghriba
on va avoir appris beaucoup par exemple
mais oui mais là ils vont enlever toute
l'histoire de lavage de mains même des
épiceries ben ils sont pas sûrs que
l'actuel dossier ça c'est pas le toucher
c'est vraiment là dans la ccl aérosols
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne plus
que je suis vont ils vont vraiment levé
les doutes les lavages de paniers jamais
négatif la vie c'est moi mais je sais
pas où on est lassé des produits
extrêmement fort pour les mêmes
élections et qui travaille en milieu là
qui sont obligés de se laver mais comme
quarante cinq fois par jour ils doivent
devenir les mérites et les maladies
professionnelles prévues dans les gens
qui travaillent dans le système de santé
entre la maison des maîtres est acquis
mais ce qui explique je reviens sur ce
qui est hésitante au t2 que toi tout
vécu un épisode d'anxiété est temps pour
quelqu'un de mature action pour ça
permet d'avoir un peu plus d'empathie
pour le monde des plantes comme les
plombiers qui passe tout dérape le ton
monte on dirait que de comprendre plus
en plus ces gens là ça du tout c'est
adhérer à moi mettons si ça faisait six
mois que je me sentais quand le senti
cette soirée le oui prisonniers prenant
que je serai en train de dire
elle a enlevé nous le masque levé le
couvre-feu n'a pas de bon sens les gens
vont mourir le probablement que je serai
en train de remettre en question
vraiment beaucoup
la cli mesure je mesure sanitaire est
ici parce que moi ça m'est pas arrivé
chez at t on en parlait souvent j'ai
tout le temps vrai finalement ce
prospectus est supporter on masque d'une
vis ta vie à attin 9h30 mais si je me
sentais ça faisait six mois car tout les
soirs je me sentais comme ça je réponds
allemande renders questionner vraiment
beaucoup ne serait pas un restaurateur
qui voit son commerce s'en aller
tranquillement grèce et s'est hissé son
loyer publié l'argent ça envoie l'argent
sans avant ça fait presque un an et demi
qu'ils sont fermés au vif est remis
perdre et ça doit te plus rentable pour
cela on peut comprendre qu'il ya pas ou
plus d'empathie puis mais je sais que
pense que c'est ce qui manque en général
l'empathie l'empathie campagne si envers
les gens qui sont complotistes envers
tout le monde en fait envers tout le
monde que pas l'opinion tout parce que
la personne était c'était gentil vaccin
les anti vaccin aussi les antilles
faction aussi parce que tu es toi
peut-être un par un c'est dur d'avoir
va-t-il varsity y est les goliaths
maintenant si on le fait tous par geste
social on veut légaliste mais il ya de
l'ignorance beaucoup eu de la peur est
mauvaise information formation des
mauvaises fréquentations city des gens
qui vont amener vers qui vous qu'ils
vont dire écoute vidéo le petit après
ceux ci s'étaient pas être cité pas
outillés pour démystifier ces vidéos là
qu'on t'envoie où ces entrevues l'heure
où les vidéos de 2 millions de gains de
radio québec s'est amusé ça sexy non
monsieur moi j'avais écouté ses
conférences parce que j'étais curieux
ouais je curieux
le man is her j'aimerais saluer des
disques est toujours avec nous sa finale
justement il est habile lui il s'exprime
bien
charisma tient les gens adhèrent à lui
donne à son pays par le besoin
genève arrive un scandale on va serait
temps qu'ils ont su sais pas combien de
maryse le sang rouge et argent mais mais
lui avait fait une publication disant
qu'ils étaient tout le monde en parle
ben oui et c'était justement c'est ça
notre y avait surtout des gens non ceci
n'est pas vrai oui c'est notre chichi
pas combien de courriels pour que lui
soit invitée mais ça ne peut pas faire
ça une responsabilité de diffuseurs tu
peux prendre quelqu'un comme ça en ondes
très pentu convention exactement quel
revérifier qu'est ce qui dit il très à
béliveau cité des études vous citez des
choses vo cité des des médecins qui sont
à contre courant est en ordre il y en a
qui sont fournis et les scientifiques
qui disent que le changement climatique
c'est pas vrai oui il y en a 5 % sur i
télé la face et quelles sont les
missions puis des fois cette arrivée de
ce mets ton si à pau
alain vadeboncoeur soumission ou
quelqu'un comme seul
[Musique]
ici quelqu'un qui dit quelque chose nous
mêmes fausses informations sarkozy les
scientifiques sont eux aussi maligne
karl weiss l'année passée avant la
pandémie était venu tout le monde en
parle en février avant que ça commence
puis il faut aller revoir l'entrevue
elle est sur youtube puis ils nous
rassuraient mais lui il se trompait pas
mais au moment où on se parle est un
vrai mais cette ville et ça c'était
encore des rumeurs il n'y avait pas ça
comme chirez autour du 20 février
ces gens savent à noter les premiers
cachets net ou benzema il faut vraiment
pas s'inquiéter ça va bien je crois pas
que c'est possible qu'une pandémie si
qui va s'installer parce que les l'été
les progrès technologiques sont si
grands que moi j'écoutais objets
rassurer tout le monde
d'après les scientifiques il faut
apprendre parler c'est parce qu'il faut
prendre au moment où il nous parle
c'est exact à la lumière de la meilleure
information qu'on aux pires que c'est
c'est tout le temps le consensus photo
regarde plus ce qu'ils étaient une
personne directement ses mais leur faire
la peau longtemps fait et geste
images-là apparaître les métiers avec
guillaume lemay thivierge qui était lui
même comme partie sur une chaire un
petit puisque toutes les choses qui les
ya mis les personnes qui quittent est
vraiment à l'oeil expert corriger ces
ressources est arrivé à des milliers de
fois de l'ère blanc
la semaine dernière et qui avait pas
d'exploit rayon peut pas prévoir qui
vaut réagir par les cas fera toujours
qu'on aille à un expert la semaine
d'après il semble avoir une petite
confusion la semaine passée là-dessus
pilote finalement les deux médecins qui
étaient là ont un peu démenti ce que
l'hôtel et yasmin avait remettait touch
est paraît il à quelqu'un quand tu peux
pas offrir un facteur qui justement tu
reçois de monde samedi y sont ce pas
convaincre la direction de la rhétorique
le chemin mettant un james a fait sauter
un esprit moins je peux je m'étais
s'effacer d'être convaincu pis je sais
pas tu acceptes ans
on a longtemps privilégié pas les débats
à tout le monde à voir quand j'ai
tellement aimé mieux qu'il ya une
personne qui parle son point de vue la
semaine suivante je reçois l'autre point
de vue parce que sinon tout le monde se
coupe
c'est pas fini que c'est la personne qui
communique le mieux qui va gagner
quant à patrick c'est elle qui a raison
ça va consister en un combat oratoire
que les français soient beaucoup mais
ici c'est bon mais quelqu'un c'était
quand c'était pas un direct je me
rappelle que des fois et avait des des
textes qui apparaissait quand quelqu'un
dit quelque chose qui était pauvre et
ouais il est des lapsus mais tout juste
si on a racheté jeudi 7 diffusé le 10
membres assistent avec un temps de faire
des textes pour exact y avait quelque
chose qui était juste comme complètement
aberrant et avait un texte qui dort sur
ses pas la vraie information voici la
vraie information le fait qu'on faisait
jeudi pour le dimanche 6 impasse a dit
plus
c'est d'après ses seuls avantages
directs par exemple il épouse s'est fait
litres avantages et les désavantages que
je trouvais le plus difficile c'est pas
nécessairement direct c'est l'absence de
public ces quêtes et gags tombent à plat
il ya personne pour les rêves les
invités qui sont ressorte extrêmement
nerveux qui ont ils réagissent pas comme
des gens normaux l'ipo ils sont mal ils
comprennent pas tout ce que tu dis que
tu es arrivé que vous avez jusqu'à
rappeler entrevue au complet c'est drôle
ça arrivait avec pierre lapointe la
première entrevue télé qui a donné
guilhamat lgv au complet tu es trop
nerveux mais il trouva que ça lui
rendait poche c est que ça allait lui
lui nuire parce qu'il était peut-être un
petit peu trop prétentieux
il n'était pas connu puisque c'était
enlevé l'entreprise au conflit avaient
appelé à tout faire et et on enlève sa
part pu tout le monde peut y avait
expliqué à son entourage aussi que
c'était peut-être pas lui rendre service
que de diffuser cette entrevue la
rentrée aujourd'hui pierre est très
habile selon lui avoir qui donne
vraiment des entrevues je pense qu au
début vous les pauvres tels que savait
qu'ils étaient pas le plus habile le
chemin enfin ils s'expriment super bien
mais c'est yahia apprivoiser ce qui
l'est aussi tranquillement le personnage
si tu arrives et d'autres fois il me le
mon souvenir non la pâte est une fiscal
et une fois mais je me rappelle pas de
sens non ouais ouais ouais
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on ne soit
même et au match et le porte à porte et
rama nathan on soit cas évidemment que
les mouches automates et pas grand chose
de moi là je me soit juste date heureux
d'avoir du plaisir gecol j'ai déjà
autour de moi qui sont décédés mon ami
dominique montre mon ancien conjoint
andré qui est mort aussi
ac je sais que la vie est courte puis
que ça peut s'arrêter n'importe quand
alors je sors je me sois tout juste
d'être bien puis d'avoir du plaisir on
le souhaite aussi
vraiment merci infiniment de vimy bord
merci aux cours le sans filtre ça passe
bien quatre heures et vingt quatre
preneurs et demi une heure et demie
passée ben merci infiniment merci à vous
merci d'avoir écouté ses podcasts
jusqu'à la fin j'espère que vous avez
apprécié la conversation ça prouve que
vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans-fil pas de
casser on vous remercie vraiment
beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe il ya sur petra non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu'on les
tombes donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pga mais on fait aussi
des encore moins de filtres qui sont
exclusifs aux membres pétrole ou est ce
que on parle d'homme ni que l'émoi de la
conversation qu'ont bien d'avoir ce
qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets qu'on voulait aborder ou
qu'on abordés pendant le podcast donc
allez sur notre page rituel mais le lien
vers sa voix dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fonte